hi this is John Roca from Collider I'm
here with two hot looking dudes Aldous
Hodge and Greg Kinnear okay they are
they could be brothers all this I think
this whole town is obviously gonna take
notice of you after this film and I
think certainly city on a hill I love
that show knee-deep in that show right
now but see what you bring to this role
man it's incredible to watch your work
and watch your process you stepping in
you're taking on a man who has existed
who's gone through so much here what was
your biggest obstacle stepping into the
shoes or cleats of Bryan fans leads my
biggest obstacle was just getting his
spirit accurate I wanted to portray the
brand that I knew and then I understood
and when it comes to this sort of
situation in topic you might see that
someone may go through it
with bitterness or with anger and the
times that he was frustrated and at
times that he was really confused or
downtrodden about certain things I
didn't want to exhibit anger because
that's not who he is he is a ball of I
think positivity and enlightened at the
point where we really introduced or the
majority of the the timeframe that I
play Bryan is where he's elevated to a
point of understanding what peace is
he's still fighting for right
understands what it is so he's not he's
removed from me and I want people to see
the the pure essence of who this man is
and the purity of who he is you know
he's a great person he's inspired me and
I hope that people get that from
yeah there's almost a George Foreman
aspect to it all I got angry he was
before he had his conversion right to do
the guy's selling his George Foreman
girls agree give that back scream one
moment that really stands out for you
man is that mall are you delivered to
yes Justin Brooks whenever you're like
telling him the old man taking the
oldest have see me how like what would
you channel in when you got to that
place for that monologue Oh him all day
yeah so Brian and I we talked about
every scene especially the major scenes
at length prior to shooting and we would
talk throughout them so that particular
day it was a little tough for me to
navigate some of the emotional notes I
wanted to hate for consistency and we
were shooting in a courthouse took Brian
to the side we were just sitting in a
stairwell him and I by ourselves and you
know talking to him about this entire
process as it played out for him in
reality and then we were both connecting
on the hardships in both of our lives
growing up how our families were
affected by certain things and all that
and we kind of had you know we had an
emotional moment we both ended up crying
you know were just two brothers out
there come talking about the the good
old days and were crying about what we
went through but it was sort of a
release of we've survived you know so
when it got to the scene I went back in
there and I was able to find it because
we had a moment of being able to be you
know brothers who were supporting each
other emotional yeah yeah so that Greg
you are so good in this role as well
kind of walking into another sort of
sports-related movie like you did it
invincible but you know there's a
massive fan club for Greg Kinnear
whenever you take a role people take
notice and what is it about Justin
Brooks that spoke to you or this this
film did they chase you down like eldest
chase down Justin Brooks in the movie or
rather Bryan chase you know III actually
started for me I had a cup of coffee
with Tom Shadyac you know script Brian
banks you know Tom Shadyac liar liar a
lot of big huge comedies in his past I
was like this is not funny and I
remember just sitting down with him and
hearing his passion for this story and I
hadn't I didn't know Tom's story either
you know and kind of transformation he's
been through and and of course you hear
about wrongly confuse you know convicted
people and it's kind of a drone that's
all in our lives all the time this
you know getting out of jail 30 years
later it's so frustrating
yeah but the details of all this came
together for me in such a huge way when
I when I learned of the story and and
how Brian is is an incredible guy and in
his story and how he represents so many
other people have been wrongly convicted
and how that tags to the guy Justin
Brooks I play runs the California's its
project I mean they've they've
exonerated over 30 people who have been
wrongly accused sometimes 20-30 years in
jail and aid that at the end of the film
yes yeah you'll get all that sense and
you know first and foremost it's a hell
of a movie - great story but it also is
the kind of film where you'll drive home
and you'll think about how this affects
your own life and it will give you some
great perspective I certainly did for me
one last one last question fee all this
because I work for a Collider we talk
about subir movies all the time like
Panther - a Green Lantern what would you
want to be in I guess whichever is
hiring better Jon Stewart out there a
Green Lantern if Jon Stewart came around
that would be fantastic
I'm I grew up a big fan of Marvel and DC
grab now I was a kind of it did the
whole thing I got into the business so
my mom could buy me Batman toys that's
what yeah
so if Jon Stewart came around man I'm
open I'm down I'm down - I love it
alright there you go thanks everybody
out of this John roca for Collider Brian
banks go see this thing it's gonna move
you